hi there steve kaufman here to talk
about language learning and in
particular to talk about how we can get
better
at the nuts and bolts the structures of
a language speak better
and i'm gonna follow this
this is essentially an introduction to
me
using link and showing you how i focus
in on phrases save phrases tag phrases
and how i do that
but
essentially you know
in language learning in my experience
which is now 50 years or more of
conscious language learning
the bulk of my time has been listening
and reading
except in those situations where i was
in an environment where the language was
spoken like japan or france
and however you do have to spend some
time on the structures and the less you
are in the country the more you have to
do this in my view this sort of
deliberate
uh trying to focus in on certain things
that you may not notice or improving
your ability to notice
so i i refer sometimes this is maybe an
80 20 situation 80 percent of the time
is sort of big picture learning top-down
learning listening and reading enjoying
things in the language but 20
has to be focusing focusing in on some
of the frequently used expressions
grammatical structures pronunciation and
so forth more deliberate learning
that percentage is much smaller if you
live where the language is used because
then you're using it all the time and
you're you're noticing more
uh so
uh you will see that uh
i will discuss in the video you're about
to see two things really one is these
mini stories
which i have referred to before where we
try to use the most common verbs in the
language
where
uh we in each story the vocabulary
repeats three times four times so
they're great for listening to
especially while doing other tasks
because they are kind of interesting
little stories but mostly you're
listening for
these
structures these grammatical forms that
maybe you missed the first time and then
you get it the second time or the third
time because the basic vocabulary
uh
repeats so often that you know what the
vocabulary is you're starting to focus
in on the structures you're starting to
focus in on the nuts and bolts
and if on top of that you can
using link for example or in some other
way
focusing on focusing on phrases save
phrases review the phrases identify
what kind of grammatical sort of
function this phrase represents all of
this helps you notice and helping you
notice is dealing with that 20
making you more alert to the language so
that when you're in the major activity
which is your you know
enjoyable and interesting listening and
reading you're picking up on things
because if you don't notice things you
can't learn those things so developing a
greater awareness of the language is
very important
i think the many stories are a great way
to do this and if within the mini
stories you save and tag phrases that
even heightens your awareness more i'm
going to get back to these many stories
we have 60 already written they're being
translated maybe people out there want
to help us write more stories in the
same format we'd be happy to have more
volunteers now i will let you uh have a
look over my shoulder so to speak as i
use link to save phrases and tag phrases
and how i do that
so here you are at my workspace my
lesson page and link
i have to tell you that i normally do
this on my ipad
using the
ilink app but i don't know how to
you know get a screen capture of that
i'm using movavi software which once i
figured it out looks
pretty good so i'm going to start here
with russian and then i will flip to a
few other languages
because
with russian i have a very large
vocabulary it says here that i have 92
000 known words
uh of course in slavic languages there
are many forms of each were so
i don't want to put too much importance
on this
number but it means that i know a lot of
words so if i read
literature or
you know newspaper articles basically i
know
most of the words however i still
struggle with the structure especially
when i'm speaking and so
we need to spend time on the nuts and
bolts which is the grammar the structure
the use of the most common words give
and take go and come
and that's where the many stories come
in the many stories
here i'm going to open this happen to be
at number 17. we have 60 many stories
they're not all available in all
languages
the first level which is 1 to 20 only
has the present tense all the stories
have a high
focus on the most common verbs of the
language
these mini stories consist of three
parts two different sort of
points of view
plus questions so that the vocabulary
repeats they're great for listening to
over and over again to work on
the basics and you can do this at any
level you can do it when you're starting
out to learn the language or you can go
back in as i'm doing
as a means of trying to nail down some
of the aspects of grammar which give me
trouble
so let's open up
this story here now in addition to
listening to these many stories which i
think are ideal for this purpose
uh you heard the text of the speech
there by the way i have turned on my
automatic text-to-speech
one thing that i find useful is to go in
and then save phrases so here for
example
i can look at the individual verb
itself go home
or by
the phrase is whatever i have saved i
could have included mark here but i
chose not to
i want as much as possible short phrases
that i think could repeat elsewhere so i
start to get these phrases in different
texts that i'm studying now i have
tagged this phrase first of all as
direction because i'm going home and in
slavic languages
going to and from something is sometimes
in the accusative case
sometimes in the genitive case i
apologize to those of you who don't know
what cases are but
cases in slavic languages and in german
and other languages are
different forms of nouns that change
depending on the function of the noun
in the sentence and so i've tagged it
for direction i also tag it for motion
because in slavic languages verbs of
motion are sometimes difficult for a
non-native speaker to get a hang of so i
now i'm creating
a bunch of phrases that will either be
tagged as direction or tagged as motion
so that when i uh review in vocabulary
which i'll show you shortly i can see a
bunch of these phrases concentrated and
i'll get into that in greater detail if
i move along
is a form
again it's the genitive case of rabota
which is work
why is it in the genitive
again
because it's from like
the from meaning with
is in the genitive so i've also tagged
this as direction all right
if we go on here for example
so this is this time i've saved the
whole sentence
you can say whatever you want as a
phrase so if now i if i were doing it
again i might do it in a different order
but
yet
is a verb of motion so i tagged it as
motion motion
is
instrumental he's using the steering
wheel of his car so to speak but it's an
expression that means he's at the wheel
of his car and swaye mashini is genitive
so again just to show you that i can
then go into the vocab section and find
all of the phrases that i tagged for
whatever i tag now
with russian i'm not doing as much other
than this focus on the mini stories
because we just started creating them
and they're a great place for me to work
on my grammar i have been much more
active
in for example ukrainian
so let's open up ukrainian
so here we see that recently i've read
this was an article from rajya sabha
where they also had the audio
this is my conversation report from my
tutor this is an article that's
basically appears automatically from
visoki zamok which is a newspaper in la
viv and so forth but here if i go to my
vocabulary list
you'll see that i have
uh you know 32 000 links that i've
created words and phrases
if i just go to phrases i see that have
4540 phrases which is still a lot to
review so i tend to want to filter these
okay
now i can sort them by
the alphabetically by when i created
these links for example i want to see
the most recent ones
and i can look at for example what did i
save in the accusative for example so
here i have my list of
phrases that i have saved
now it's possible that uh
in some of these for example okay here's
here's an example of something i've said
na moment anexi
at the time of the annexation of crimea
it's moment is accusative
but it's also an expression of time at
the moment or at the time of
annexi
are both genitive so i've saved this now
one thing i can do
is to
oh by the way if i'm not sure
that i have
all of these are in fact the accusative
and i've tried to look them up
beforehand to make sure
but i can
uh
send these
two
i can simply export them and send them
as a file to my tutor and say please
check that i have tagged these correctly
and she might come back and say no these
are not correct
the other thing i can do and which i do
do
is record these so that i have the
english followed by
uh the ukrainian so
it's a practice in pronunciation one by
one odin
and then i say trust alexander
lukashenko
at the time the annexation of crimea
moment anexi
and so i have to listen to the english
i've got to think of it and then i hear
it in my pronunciation and i can do it
again a month later and maybe my
pronunciation improves but it also gives
me the opportunity to be reviewing these
phrases away from the computer while in
the car while doing dishes and so forth
so another language that i have been
sort of busy with is greek so we can
quickly flip over to greek
and uh here
uh with my mini stories i'm up to
42
uh in the mini stories and uh where i
have saved a bunch of phrases so again i
can have a look
and it works very much the same way
i have all these i have 10 000 saved
links but in terms of phrases i have
2600 and if i look at filters let's
again go to accusative
and so then uh
so if they're all uh
you know in alphabetical order that can
be helpful
uh or if you prefer you can look at them
by creation date
so
[Music]
a lot is
uh
so there i can look at them scrambled
alphabetically however i want to do them
okay
now
let us go to a language that might be
more familiar to many of you let's go to
french
all right so here in french
again we have the mini stories
so i can go in here
and
start saving some phrases so
andre
now not everyone knows that potita me
means girl
so it's worth saving that so you can say
that
maybe you don't tag that you just say
that as a phrase
uh okay
amisa
now
one of the things that you might want to
phrase is save is separate
and you might wanna
and say save it as adjective
because
because in french the agreement of the
adjective is so important so saputita me
is probably worth saying
you know
okay
now
again that's another thing
he goes shopping that's an expression
you might want to tag depends what
you're interested in you might want to
tag that for
you know
words that relate to buying things
there's lots of words that relate to
buying whatever you want
let me just see if there's something
grammatical
again there's a lot of phrases
you might want to go motion because it's
what the funny thing is that
in all these languages
there are sort of some somewhat similar
issues
uh you know if we're looking at at
motion again
motion issue now bear in mind
at this level
all the verbs are in the present
uh you know
very common you know shady it's it's a
french form now what i find is if i tag
that promotion again
i'm often able to review more than one
thing in the phrase so i'm
not only capturing the verdict of motion
like go home but also shady which is a
very
common expression so that just gives you
a bit of a sense in different languages
of a how useful the
mini stories are
because as you see here it was uh
whatever uh eli you know
so you might want to again say this
now sometimes the transition
is wrong and so it's she
she her name is sarah so you can
actually change this
her name is sarah
okay and uh
voila
voila so it's all jour
and then we have the questions
so again
you may not be comfortable voting
cuisine
the texas speech is a little messed up
there
uh and you might put question maybe you
are not comfortable with the way they
form questions
uh
in french
okay so but it's really something that
you designed for yourself how best to
use these tags and then to review them
in the vocabulary list so i think that's
enough right now um
i won't go to the vocabulary page in
french take you back to the main
lesson page
um
i will go into if people are interested
i can go into more detail in another
video about how we import lessons
uh how we select content to learn from
and so forth so that's it i hope that
was useful bye for now
[Music]
you